you have been very open to about your
struggles and what you've been going
through and I want it advertised and
what it aired and I want them to see
that because I'm sick of it because it's
hurting me
why is it important for you to be
transparent like that I think one day
something clicked and I was like you
know what I have to be honest I can't
keep living this perception of other
people within my life so you know I I
have to change that what went into your
decision to go to rehab
well I struggle from an eating disorder
so I had sent seven ulcers I was like
115 pounds
super malnourished what did they do to
help you get to where you are oh my god
they were they were amazing it was tough
a little bit on myself but the aloe
house where I went was incredible they
just helped figure it out for me like
what what was going on with me and
there's other you know there's things
going on like I suffer from PTSD I have
a lot of trauma from my past and a lot
of loss so that's you know that's
something I have to deal with on a daily
basis you went back why did you decide
why was important to go back because I
wasn't ready for the world hmm I wasn't
ready I wasn't ready to be able to you
know deal with the triggers and
pressures around me do you feel like
you're an addict
of course I'm an addict yeah - I don't
have to feel like it I am what are you
what are your addictions I mean right
now none you don't smoke anymore all
right no I smoked I told everybody where
I was at you know I was like oh you know
when I finish here I probably will be
smoking weed and that's just something
that is a part of my it's my ritual kind
of it's not it's just something you used
to smoke it's it's kind of like how like
the Marley's did it mm-hmm like like I'm
in love with the Marley what does
sobriety mean to you if you still
indulge in some of those things I'd have
to say staying off of certain things
that like in our state like staying in
what I'm doing right now that's like
what I like suffer with PTSD and all
that stuff like so I mean were you
taking medication for that of course I
am now do you feel more at ease now that
you're out of rehab and the anxiety
maybe isn't there not much no it's it's
actually a little bit more difficult
it's scary you know when you spend so
much time in a facility you know and
then you come back out you know I have
to kind of I don't know reimburse
this other person it's metamorphosis so
that's what I'm going from from from
rehab to all of a sudden I'm in the
outside world and I don't have people
monitoring me and checking my blood
pressure in doing their job so it's I
mean it's it's crazy what do you have to
say to your fans who have had your back
oh my god the fans have been so
supportive it's crazy because after I
make a transformation like I transform
from 115 to 160 pounds 115 pounds yes in
less than 50 days how did you do that I
did detox and but through that detox
like I just I gained like two pounds
every day 28 percent of body weight I
get a game do you look in the mirror now
and are you okay with what you say oh
yeah I there's no body dysmorphia I mean
I had body dysmorphia too because I was
like so skinny so I would use like those
face to apps and everything like that
just to try to like you know like make
myself look bigger what's the one
pattern that would scare you if you felt
yourself going back there again what's
the one thing that I would say like
loneliness I would say like loneliness
but you know what I can't I just can't
let that happen
you